hey there viewer I just want to let you
know that we are entering a new era here
at Lauder with credit The Daily Show is
going to continue of course as it always
has but we're going to be doing more
change my mind's more Road shows more
Crowder confronts than ever before
because enough of you have actually
joined up at mug club and we're moving
into a whole new grand studio space
bringing in new guests who will be here
for the entire week we're really excited
appreciate the support and so if we get
deep platformed we know we'll always
have you but tomorrow will actually be
releasing the latest in our series
Crowder confronts with someone who
actively wanted to kill and offered to
pay actually for others to kill members
of ice and wanted to get his hands on me
for years probably the most hostile
Crowder confronts that we've done but
here's a teaser that's gonna be tomorrow
August 21st
I believe watch enjoy see then
your wish is my command sir how are you
yeah I've even said you want a piece of
me for a long time
hey kids